with his first appearance in the
original Texas Chainsaw Massacre
Leatherface instantly earned a spot
among the all-time classic horror movie
villains his story has become somewhat
muddled through out a series of sequels
prequels and reboots but don't worry
we're here to sort it out for you
Leatherface looks like the kind of
monster that director tobe Hooper
probably saw in a nightmare
but he wasn't a product of Hooper's
imagination he and the rest of the
cannibalistic Sawyer family were loosely
based on a real person serial killer and
grave robber Edie Dean who was known as
the butcher of Plainfield several
residents of Plainfield Wisconsin went
missing over the years and Gein was
found responsible for their deaths an
investigation of his home resulted in
authorities finding organs stored in
jars and masks made of human skin in the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre
Leatherface doesn't just wear one mask
he actually switches between a few
depending on the scene why does he
change his mask according to the late
Gunnar Hansen who originally played
Leatherface the masks were not just
creepy accessories they were actually
the only way Leatherface could really
express himself Hansen said the mask
really determined his personality who he
wanted to be that day determined what
mask he put on so when Drayton comes
home with Sally
Leatherface is wearing the old-lady mask
and he's wearing an apron and carrying a
wooden spoon he wants to be domestic
helpful in the kitchen at dinner he
wears a different face the pretty woman
which has makeup in the 40-plus years
since the original film was released
different films in the franchise have
explored slightly altered origin stories
for Leatherface the 2003 remake and its
2006 prequel the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
at the beginning offer up an interesting
explanation in this version
Leatherface was born disfigured from the
skin disease and his mother dies giving
birth to him at work her boss doesn't
care about the infant's fate so he
leaves him behind in a dumpster
expecting him to die a woman named Luda
Mae Hewitt finds him and
Jimenez her own son naming him Thomas
he's ashamed of the way he looks so he
begins wearing a leather mask to hide
his face
this habit continues into adulthood and
eventually the mask practically became a
part of him being adopted may have saved
Thomas from dying in that dumpster
but the Hewitt's aren't exactly a warm
loving family just like the Sawyer
family in the original Texas Chainsaw
Massacre they're a violent group of
cannibals
and Leatherface is doomed to be one of
them not every film featuring a young
leather face depicts him as disfigured
or diseased though the 2017 film
Leatherface which specifically explores
his childhood and teenage years takes
the story in another direction we're
introduced a leather face as a young boy
celebrating his birthday at his birthday
party
his family gives him a chance to torture
and kill a thief who tried to steal one
of their pigs but he doesn't want any
part of the violent ritual refusing to
use the chainsaw throughout the film his
mother makes it clear that she'll make
him one of them at any cost in this
version of the story it's clear that
Leatherface knows what's expected of him
but deep down he doesn't want to
participate I had people like him
they're trying to break our family apart
but we're not gonna let that happen
right
despite the creepy setting of the Sawyer
household he looks like another wise
normal child there's no sign of the skin
disease in fact there's really nothing
distinct about his physical appearance
that would set him apart from any other
kid he's certainly not having a normal
childhood though in the movie
Leatherface the title character spends a
lot of time away from his violent family
young lovers Betty and Ted come across
Jedediah Sawyer on the side of the road
Betty worries about the child's safety
follows him back to a barn hoping to
help him but the Sawyer family isn't
kind of strangers on their property and
she meets an untimely end her dad the
local sheriff arrives at the Sawyer farm
he's shocked and saddened by the scene
he discovers as retribution
he sends Jedediah away to a mental
institution despite the protests of his
mom Verna this is where the boy who will
become Leatherface spends his teenage
years under the name Jack's
Leatherface is Jedidiah leaves the
institution in a breakout after going on
the run with the nurse and a small group
of inmates he gets shot in the face and
his mother is the one who helps him
stitch up his wounds she knows that
while he's vulnerable she can sink her
claws back into him and bring him back
into the sawyer family when she puts a
chainsaw back in his hands he's ready to
use it for the first time on the sheriff
who sent him away and then shot him in
the 2006 prequel it isn't Leatherface
his mother who encourages him to give in
to his worst impulses Charlie Hewitt
Luda Mays son is the real culprit when
Leatherface loses his job at the
slaughterhouse he tries to kill his boss
when Sheriff quake tries to arrest
Leatherface Hewitt steps in and kills
him then disguises himself as Hoyt God
just killed the whole Sheriff's
Department after spending time with Hoyt
the impressionable Thomas Hewitt
completely becomes Leatherface Terrence
Evans who played old Monty in the film
said I think there was a chance
Thomas's life could have been different
but the teasing he suffered coupled with
a bad temper and following Hoyt around
like a puppy dog left room for Hoyt to
get absolute control in Leatherface the
characters first mask was from one of
his first victims the nurse who left the
mental institution with him and the
other inmates lyzzie lyzzie instantly
takes a liking to the young man but
their friendship is short-lived
after killing Hartman Jedediah chases
after lizzie with his chainsaw she trips
when her foot gets caught in a bear trap
Lizzi pleads with him for mercy but when
she insults the Leatherface his mother
all hope is lost for her he swings his
chainsaw decapitates her and makes his
first mask from her skin in the 2006
prequel Leatherface his killing spree
begins when health inspectors shut down
the slaughterhouse where he works that
matches up with the detail in the
original Texas Chainsaw Massacre where
all the men and the Sawyer family worked
at the local slaughterhouse when they
lost their jobs they turned to
cannibalism when sally the final
survivor out of her group of friends in
1974
is tortured and taunted during dinner
with the Sawyer's they suggest that
grandpa should be the one to kill her
because he was the best worker in the
old slaughterhouse he's too weak to
finish the job and she escapes
Leatherface is one of those classic
movie villains who wasn't necessarily
born evil
but knowing his backstory doesn't make
the original Texas Chainsaw Massacre any
less frightening don't give any rides to
strangers if you can help it you like it
makes it real good check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite horror
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]